was ja 19
also violinen hat weniger auf jedenfalls
gitarre ja ok ja aber ich glaube banjo
oder sowas hat vielleicht noch mehr
dann ist es das was ich nicht war
ich hab schafe ich laufe über aldo juni
sind monster und hätte ich dachte
einfach koordinaten okay ich nochmal die
koordinaten jetzt fix 160 160 und traten
beide gepanscht haben der bringen das
essen mit
seid ihr denn alle den er übrigens eine
neue frage realisieren auf geht's was
haltet ihr von area 51 und anderen alien
geschichten sagt edgar 1 lp das doch
schon film ja ich war nie das ist eine
theorie schwester meine schwester kennt
den haupt vfx macher sonst etwas von
diesem film ist auch ein film war der
film meet you merry merry fiftyone ist
doch dass mit den außerirdischen die da
so geht nur mäßig wie was dann auf die
apartheid anspielbereit
ich kann gar nichts mit dem ich hab das
mal gehört aber ich weiß es nicht aber
was ich sagen könnte wäre dass ich denke
schon dass es irgendwo anders noch leben
gibt das ist klar dass das noch geht er
so aber das hässliche bakterien zu tun
haltet ihr von 53 und anderen alien
geschichten also die basis
ich hab da ja dazu kann ich erst mal
nichts sagen
also bzw
weil ich das nicht kenne nicht geguckt
habe aber ich kann sagen muss es nicht
guckt es ist nicht nur der film ist ein
mythos video ist ein mythos
aber es ist ein film und was er glaube
ich auch meint noch reicht es doch
gerade als ob es das ist was auf die
aparte ein schwerer weg werden
inzwischen redet schreibt ihr dabei
district 9 ist das oder landen die
aliens einfach in johannesburg
aber nicht den von ghetto wohn alter
nein als ein motto wenn du mal so ist
kein begriff höheren mass für eine
gegend wo asoziale leute wohnen wie es
jetzt gebraucht wird sondern ganz
ursprünglich ein leben das geht auch
dass das geht auch das warschauer ghetto
so aber das ist man gewohnt ein ghetto
war da nur das wohn und es auch als
militärisch bewacht wird und so weiter
ich bin jetzt bei koordinate ich habe
nicht mal eine schere mit er hat jetzt
auf 540
ich kann mir nicht ihre bauern also die
schafe stehen bei exakt x100 30 - 30 ich
bin etwas da ja ich hab auch noch gleich
pumpkins mitgenommen sehr gut wir zeitig
aber natürlich denn die schafe bitte
hier locken mit einem charme habe ich
vielleicht heimlich seine la la la la la
la
ein schamhaar mit denen auch
barbara norgay sie sofort ist also eher
frage zurückkommen was haltet ihr denn
jetzt von jedem eine eigene meinung
nicht allein da steht an die fängt an
ich hasse science fiction ich mag
science fiction um die theorie ist okay
jetzt kommt lehne ich bin dran kraft hat
keine meinung von kräfte keine meinung
der wäre jetzt ein kleiner ich werde
dann nachher stimmt nicht ich finde ja
wie gesagt ich kann dazu halt nicht viel
sagen weil total dann halt nicht
gebildet bin okay sein opfer bis das
trio gehört zum bildungspolitik ohne
spielt uns zum prekariat
aber ich auf jeden fall gibt es irgendwo
aliens auch wenn jetzt gibt's gar nicht
doch gibt es sogar schon auf maß wird
auch durch wasser gefunden oder irgendwo
in der nähe der sinn des haus am see es
ist es dass sony da kommt noch was dran
hallo hallo davon junge ja anrufen
ich suche die schafe us-star andy hast
du kein open der der hirte x100 30 30
ich gebe ihnen hörte wie heidi ja aber
ich bin ich habe ja am 8
so ich besonders ein bisschen holz wir
brauchen noch holz oder hat er kommt
ärger bei den betroffenen
die ganzen öfen kommen vorwand ich glaub
es steht schon mehr als bei euch erst
gar nicht wo ihr euer ding gebaut am
sporthaus am ende von deinem haus zu den
us ski sondern geradeaus weiter das
führt das hübsche gebilde das was
schöneres gibt es um 17 20 folgen von
eurem together hattest du auch nur
einfach einen rechteckigen raum mit
erscheint weiß man und der bund für die
scheiße aber das muss man ihm lassen ein
haus aber schöne aussicht mit tnt
bombardiert an erster noch mehr kabel
ich habe die cd kann nur ohne eure hilfe
gebaut hat sogar funktioniert ja
besucher getroffen
ja da hast du dich selber mal so ich war
ja noch hand betriebsfeier
prähistorische ja ich hatte nicht so
viel repeater dienstag also weiter voll
haben wir nahrung
ein thema wird auf die jagd auf die jagd
gehen
mach lieber mehr höfen
ja ich war immer gleich warum habe ich
keinen knochen dann hätte ich jetzt weit
zu machen können ich habe aus dem ofen
knochenhart man wolle von den ganzen
charme einer von euch ist unter der erde
ich habe ja auch hingehört im keller
hast du hast du irgendwie stopp oder wie
zb naja weil das land noch das volk in
minute 37 minuten zeit also aber dies
ist ja alles so geht's 1 1 über gesagt
gesagt ich hatte gesagt ich schieße
sagte einmal hallo und tschüss
ja ich hab keinen bock jemand wird es
wäre viel zu aufwändig dass wir viel zu
professionell musste sich anstrengen
nachdenken es geht ja nicht
ich nur sagen darf ich pop nehmen was er
einst hat er jetzt auch oben gut dabei
trat wieder hingeschmissen
ich konnte mich wieder anrufen reinlegen
gesagt hat kann ich wieder an meiner
gesetze ins haus duell auf beck kommt
noch einmal an und ich ziehe meinen
ich habe 17 okay gut mir ist nicht egal
ich habe einiges los ich jetzt gerade
sehr gut ich besorgte marco ich hätte
das gerade zum ersten mal diese das
letzte update wurden ja die berge hören
in barricks sprechen will be um sehr
richtig geil wie kassier bleibt ja also
das fand vor ist schon ziemlich gestimmt
hätten auch immer irgendwo das doch nur
im holz extreme hitze die sehr groß aus
das wäre ja nichts drauf nur noch größer
gegenüber beginnen die bis 256 weisen
gefunden warum nicht der strom habe
schon als erfolg ja ich hab's wäre hier
ein skelett dann hätte ich jetzt nach
hause geholt da habe ich nicht so
weiter im text
häuser in the text die diskussion ist
hier rum zählen deswegen kann ich gerade
nicht so viel reden dann reden wir für
dich ich multitaskingfähig okay erinnert
immer für mich so wie ich rede ich bin
dumm ich bin doof alle hassen mich das
beschreibt es ganz genau wenn ich gut
was brauchen wir noch glas ich hab ja
auch gerade sand mit marcel wüst
was einfach er ist ein sander haus
besonder hausverstand
das haus hat auch einen kleinen eingang
anders sein
deine schwester hat mit ihrer flöte von
vor zehn jahren den internet anschluss
gefunden
ja ich telefoniere fall mit dem finger
aufeinander zu tun will die devise ich
habe das gleiche meint schwester tiere
führte von frühjahr wieder gefunden
alles klar
die eher versteckt hat ja also die die
schwester hatte im keller versteckt
eigentlich gefunden das hab ich hab
gesagt aus krankhafter seine kosten
kommt bei ihm seine witze was ist hier
los
ok ich weiß ich weiß dass der nächste
schritt kommt wieder los hier jetzt
sagen wir nämlich nach lasst ihn
schwinge ich würde sagen dann machen wir
sand hin weil dieser hässlichen kantholz
scheiße es wird schon nach kann es sein
das kann sein
er sagt was machst du hier
sie sagt ich wollte die nummer
anprobieren damit die wurzel klar und
komm mal her komm mal her ist einfach so
kann das wäre ja wohl immer einen porno
mit einer richtig harten story das
könnte man ja mal in minecraft nach
filme wie sowie spaß
warum wäre das ist einer ich meine man
müsste ihn erfinden wieder mit test und
die nationen die die masse daran tragen
zu gucken oder mitmachen oder was macht
ja jeder das thema und das ist von denen
ihr stimmt so gut also von gutes thema
das thema kommt erst wieder eine minute
thema wieder dem krieg thema welche die
dieser sportarten weist die effektiv
kürzeste spielzeit auf basketball
eishockey handball oder ruby bla bla bla
bla rugby bestimmt nicht das ist von ice
t ist als ich meine eishockey eishockeys
aber relativ lang aber es hat natürlich
auch drei hat drei pausen sind vier mal
da die haben auch immer drei
mannschaften gab es relativ lange
handball ist glaube ich nur eine stunde
ich glaub handball falsch basketball
aber manchmal wäre es weiter gewesen